Pereiro means the dirty dog boy that's
what it means and not everybody knows
them as the dog whisperer so what do you
actually think you had this lets get why
were dogs following you had your food in
your pocket or something or when I was
poor I could afford that food in my
pocket no it's just as an energy you
know I grew up with my grandfather and
they did the same thing for him so we
moved from the farm to the city with
with already this demeanor this way of
being right so my grandfather's say
never work against mother nature you
must earn their trust respect and
they're gonna give you a beautiful gift
called loyalty
so I learned growing up with dogs follow
me off leash I never put a leash on a
dog does that mean you have no fear of
dogs a lot of people are quite
frightened about dogs well it's because
I know dog is I have no fear of yes plus
the calm part of me allows the dog - to
do this when I'm around there could I
just do that you come work up or you
they already just manage one I'll do the
dog not this part like it like this is
the real violent relaxed is in your
company they is that what you mean they
sort of feel at ease who you are in the
animal world is energy so when I work
with Oprah the dog didn't know that that
was Oprah Winfrey Yeah right what what
she knew is Oprah was nervous right
right so they don't really care what you
do for a living my clients are Harvard
graduate but they can't work at you our
don't you understand that no here's the
thing
a lot of you getting touched today and
they said we don't like Matt sees our we
don't like what he does and and it's
very controversial bullets um well
here's why it's controversial we're
going to take a clip night off am Cesar
and action and this is his new series
leader of the pack and he does make
physical contact with these dogs
some of you may object to this but have
a look and then he'll explain why he
does this there we go ready go never got
married a beautiful beautiful beautiful
beautiful here you see that touch there
it completely snaps her out of it and
telling them to focus just because she
was going yeah yeah that's what I'm
correcting right so what didn't most
people do you hold it oh cool yes I know
so the touch is just to snap the brain
from doing this yeah so now the torch in
a different part of the body notice that
I didn't touch the neck I touch the back
but it does this right you explained why
that should be there but still people
will see a kick to that dog's ribs
well they interpret it as a kick I'm
just touching a part of the body what I
can get the reaction of snap out of it
because most of the time what people do
is just pull the dog and start scream
stop it and the intention of a dog is
really one what I'm trying to remove the
dog from the dog wants to harm the
reason why this breed gets in trouble is
because people don't know how to snap
the breed out of it